саме глава держави це його
конституційний обов'язок по 106й статті
має подавати і вносити закони і поправки
до мобілізаційного законодавства ми
готові працювати зі змінами які
запропонує президент а не з тим мотлахом
яка нашкрябала одіозна депутатка За
завданням офісу президента і потім
соромно дивитися в очі і військовим і
цивільним саме глава держави це його
конституційний обов'язок по 106й статті
має подавати і вносити закони і поправки
до мобілізаційного законодавства ми
готові працювати зі змінами які
запропонує президент а не з тим мотлохом
яка нашкрябала одіозна депутатка За
завданням офісу президента і потім
соромно дивитися в очі і військовим і
цивільним